It was July of 2004, and Bill Murray was enjoying
the peak of an extremely successful career.
Not only had the iconic actor starred in some
of the most beloved comedies of the 20th Century,
including Ghostbusters and Groundhog Day,
he’d voiced the main character of the recently-released
live action Garfield movie.
It’d been a financial success, but it was
a critical flop.
Not that this bothered Bill – he was happy
with the performance... and the paycheck.
What he wouldn’t be quite as happy about
was the horrifying encounter he was about
to have with SCP – 3166.
On July 8th, Bill was enjoying a cold drink
on the porch of his luxurious Beverly Hills
home.
The sky was beginning to darken as the sun
set in the west.
It was a blissful evening.
His wife, Jennifer, was inside, watching TV.
Nothing seemed particularly out of the ordinary,
until he noticed a quick flash of orange in
the distance.
It was almost too fast to register, this large,
orange shape darting past the corner of his
eye.
For a second, he entertained the thought that
it might have been an escaped tiger, but it
was gone too fast to really tell.
Bill finished his drink and headed inside.
He’d had enough for one night.
The next morning, he got up to read the paper,
and found the Garfield movie getting slaughtered
by the critics.
One review stated “no one can accuse Garfield:
The Movie of infidelity to its source: It
faithfully conveys the banality of Jim Davis's
cartoon” Another called it“a film without
energy and without spirit.”
He put the paper down and ate his breakfast.
A few blows to the ego were worth it for the
paydays that came with big budget family films.
Just then his wife came to him with a strange
question: Were you walking around downstairs
in the middle of the night?
No, he hadn’t, he’d been sleeping like
a baby.
Why did she ask?
“Well…”
Jennifer said.
“I heard some rustling downstairs last night.
It sounded like something big.”
He hadn’t heard anything though and told
her it was probably just her imagination.
He put it out of his mind and continued about
his day.
He decided he would keep his eyes peeled for
that orange blur again though.
Bill didn’t see anything peculiar the rest
of the morning and went to a local café for
lunch.
He ordered a coffee and a cream cheese bagel,
then made a quick trip to the bathroom while
his food was prepared.
When Bill returned to his table though, he
was something strange.
Instead of a bagel, there was a large heaping
of lasagna on the table.
What was going on?
This café didn’t even serve lasagna.
Bill knew something was terribly wrong.
Things only got stranger when Bill came home
to find a small tuft of orange fur snagged
on the frame of his front door.
And it wasn’t synthetic fur like you see
on plush toys or stuffed animals.
No, this was real animal fur.
Maybe someone was just goofing off or trying
to play some weird prank on him, but it didn’t
feel like it.
Deep down, Bill Murray knew that he was in
grave danger.
Whoever, or whatever, was behind this… it
wanted to hurt him.
That night, his worst fears were realized.
Bill’s wife had left town for the week and
he was heading to the kitchen in the middle
of the night for a glass of water, when he
saw something - A huge figure moving up against
the glass door leading to his backyard.
The thing was huge, nearly seven feet tall,
with a bloated, fur-covered, misshapen body
that was pressed up against the door.
Its fur was bright, garish orange – a cartoon
orange.
Strangest of all though was the sound it was
making.
It sounded like it was purring.
Bill backed away from the door and then ran
back to his room to hide.
The whole night, he sat cowering as he heard
scratching against the walls, like something
was trying to get in.
He was terrified and too scared to do anything,
even move.
Finally, as morning broke, the noises seemed
to stop.
Bill had to do something.
He couldn’t let this nightmare go on another
night.
What if things got worse?
What if that thing managed to get inside?
He called the local police and when they arrived,
he explained the incredibly strange situation
as best he could.
He told them he was being stalked by some
kind of huge cat, or at least someone dressed
like a huge cat.
Also there was lasagna involved.
The officers interviewing him could barely
contain their laughter as he told them his
story.
A giant orange cat?
Perhaps, one of them theorized, he’d angered
some kind of obsessive Garfield fan through
his involvement in the live action movie.
After all, the original comic had been running
for years and had been extremely popular.
Who knows what kind of nut jobs were obsessed
with seeing only a faithful adaptation of
the source material?
As the officers departed, Bill was confident
that they weren’t taking him seriously.
He couldn’t rely on any of them for protection.
Thankfully, from a multi-decade movie career,
he had plenty of disposable income, and decided
to hire a private security team to protect
him while he looked into this mystery.
He had two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month.
They were armed, and given the cryptic orders
to fire on anything orange.
Meanwhile, Bill began to fall down a Garfield
rabbit hole.
He felt strangely compelled to research all
the Garfield media he could find, as though
the answer to his terrifying situation was
somehow hidden between the lines.
Bill explored the entire backlog of thousands
of comic strips.
He read the books and interviews with Jim
Davis.
He watched the cartoons and straight-to-DVD
animated movies.
Ironically for a guy who’d recently portrayed
the lasagna-loving orange cat, Bill had never
felt quite so immersed in the character before.
He found a strange pathos in the routine of
Garfield and his friends.One particular comic
really piqued his interest, though.
Originally published in October of 1989, the
comic began with Garfield being woken up by
a strange chill, an almost eerie sensation.
The character observed aloud that he didn’t
feel like he was in his own home.
He explored his little home further, trying
to find his owner Jon or his housemate and
sometimes nemesis, Odie, but found nothing.
As Garfield remarked on feeling alone, a purple
speech box delivered the sinister message:
“You have no idea how alone you are, Garfield.”
He then finds that his home looks like it’s
been abandoned for years.
The “For Sale” sign outside is practically
ancient.
Garfield slowly comes to a horrifying revelation:
Everyone really is gone, and his adventures
and friends now exist only in his imagination.
He’s trapped in a prison of his own creation,
trying to stave off his endless loneliness,
in denial about the reality of his situation.
The comic ended with a quote directly from
Jim Davis himself, saying “An imagination
is a powerful tool.
It can tint memories of the past, shade perceptions
of the present, or paint a future so vivid
that it can entice... or terrify, all depending
upon how we conduct ourselves today...”
As he read those words, Bill Murray felt a
chill down his spine.
Why had he wanted to get involved in the Garfield
movie in the first place?
What had he gotten himself into?
Before he could slip any deeper into his own
mind, Bill heard a faint, choked scream downstairs.
He felt his breath catch in his throat.
He was terrified but he needed to see what
was happening.
He carefully and quietly began to creep down
the stairs.
At the bottom, he poked his head around a
corner, and that’s when he saw a member
of his security detail lying dead on the floor.
His face was blue from asphyxiation, his mouth
was stuffed with lasagna.
It looked like he had been force-fed to death.
Bill wanted to scream but he couldn’t, or
maybe knew he shouldn’t.
Just then he heard a soft, meaty thumping
noise coming from the nearby living room.
He didn’t know why, but he felt compelled
to approach as if by forces beyond his control.
He made his way to the living room, and when
he got there, he saw where the noise was coming
from.
Bill’s jaw dropped in pure horror.
There was the other member of his security
detail, lying limp and lifeless under a giant
orange figure.
It was a grotesquely huge creature, wearing
what looked to be a kind of crude Garfield
outfit made of sewn-together cat pelts.
It stank of pasta and rotten meat.
In its giant paw, it held a golden trophy,
which it was using to pound the security guard’s
head into mush while making quiet, cat-like
purring noises.
The creature suddenly stopped and looked up,
locking eyes with Bill.
The fear of death came over him.
He froze, as the giant, freakish Garfield
stepped over Donny’s corpse, and began to
come towards him.
Bill turned and ran, but Garfield was gaining
on him.
Before he could make it to the front door,
the creature knocked him over.
He was laid out on the ground, looking up
at it, as it reached into its own body cavity
and began to pull out handfuls of lasagna.
He was just about to shove a wad of the horrible
decaying pasta into Bill’s mouth, when suddenly,
a DING was heard and the creature stopped.
It looked up, as if sniffing the air, and
then suddenly turned and lumbered towards
the kitchen.
Bill watched as the Garfield monster entered
the kitchen where, somehow, there was a steaming
hot fresh lasagna sitting in the open oven.
The creature had sensed the presence of external
lasagna, and felt the compulsion to integrate
it into its body, grabbing fistfulls and shoving
it into itself.
Just then, a group of highly trained SCP Foundation
personnel burst into the room and subdued
the creature.
It had been an ambush.
The Foundation had been tipped off to the
presence of the creature by monitoring the
local police department dispatches, and the
report of a seven foot tall comic book cat
terrorizing a Hollywood actor was definitely
worth looking into.
The monster that had almost taken Bill Murray’s
life was SCP – 3166, a deadly pataphysical
being that tends to manifest around people
somehow involved in the Garfield intellectual
property.
It appears whenever the public perception
of Garfield falls out of favor, and because
Bill had starred in the critically-panned
Garfield movie, he was currently at the very
top of SCP – 3166’s hit list.
Thankfully, he managed to survive his terrifying
ordeal, and was administered amnestics by
Foundation personnel so he could return to
his normal life.
This frightening and mysterious creature has
been around since 1989, appearing after the
publication of the haunting Garfield comic
that Bill had read that very night.
It appeared in the office of United Media,
who were the publishers of the Garfield comic
strip at the time, and began wreaking havoc.
Since then, the creature’s manifestation
has been a constant threat whenever Garfield
loses its popularity or audience.
As a result, the Foundation has spent years
as the funding source behind all Garfield
media, and even planting hypnotic memetics
into the comic strips to ensure that there
is always a loyal fanbase.
The fur is indeed real, organic cat fur, albeit
an unnaturally orange color, and instead of
organs, the creature is filled with lasagna.
Worst of all though, is that testing has revealed
that the meat in the lasagna is genetically
identical to the flesh of Garfield’s creator,
Jim Davis.
How did this thing come into existence?
Perhaps it was Jim’s sheer force of imagination
that dragged it into being.
As he himself said, “An imagination is a
powerful tool.”
All in all, it’s lucky that Bill Murray
was able to survive his encounter, and return
to his normal life – well, as normal as
life can be for Bill Murray.
And if you see Bill Murray, don’t bother
asking him about SCP – 3166.
The amnestics were quite effective, and just
as he’s fond of saying himself, no one will
ever believe you.
Now go check out “SCP – 5000 – The Suit”
and “SCP – 049 – The Plague Doctor Escapes”
for more freaky and fascinating files from
your favourite Foundation!